here now with more on how we can help
america's farmers is the president of
the national black farmers association
uh john boyd jr john welcome aboard
thanks for being on the program more
importantly uh thank you for what you do
you know i don't think we give farmers
enough credit because everything we buy
in our grocery stores you know come from
farmers and ranchers like yourself and
it's not an easy profession
um i understand you may disagree with me
politically that's fine take me on on
any issue you want but i want to know
the challenges that farmers are facing
because not only do you feed this
country you feed the world on top of
this country and we need american
farmers to have everything they need to
do their great job
thanks for having me tonight
right now we're in a crisis in america
as it relates to to farmers we're facing
an all-time high in diesel fuel that
here in virginia i'm paying five dollars
and
63 cents a gallon for for diesel fuel
we're at an all-time high for fertilizer
i'm paying
900 a ton
people that's 900 a ton for for
fertilizer 25 000
fertilizer bill that we're looking at
right now
now was the time for america to come
together
and uh support america's farmers we just
provided relief for ukraine where uh
we're going to be looking at some losses
there and the form of wheat and other
commodities but we just provided ukraine
with 40
billion dollars in aid and nothing in
that spending package for
america's farmers i know chairman scott
was trying to
work across some lines and get some
things done
america has to come back together and
work together by the same
seam
that is divided right now we're divided
uh here in our country uh on race we're
divided on
bitterness and hatred but you know love
is always greater than hate we got to
find a way to work together so that we
can get something done in this instance
this is where maybe we part ways
politically and there's no hate in my
voice here there's frustration that i'm
feeling i'm i'm frustrated
i'm frustrated that two-thirds of
americans are living paycheck to
paycheck and i believe that's
unnecessary
uh i believe giving up american energy
independence was one of the dumbest
things this country has ever done
begging opec begging iran begging
venezuela that doesn't make sense to me
maybe maybe you agree with that i don't
not having fixing the supply chain and
making sure that we have the fertilizer
for hard-working farmers like you is
unconscionable to me you feed the entire
country
well you know farmers are the last on a
totem pole as far as getting recognition
in this country you know we may not need
a doctor or
a lawyer today but every day we need an
american farmer in this country to help
feed this country and we don't get the
recognition that we need and at this
particular time we're not getting the
support that we need you know uh as
african-american farmers national black
farmers association our members are
waiting in for five billion dollars in
in federal aid that we didn't get from
last year it's it's always the weight
gain but
the example that i was making that we
were able to swiftly provide ukraine
with 50 billion dollars and i'm i'm not
against uh helping that that region of
the country and and and the cost of the
war and and the effects of the world all
of those things but we have to take care
of those at home let me ask you this i
agree with you it's america's farmers
i'm an america first guy so you don't
have to convince me um can i ask you uh
what do you farm how many acres do you
farm tell me a little bit about what you
do every day
well i'm uh i've been farming for 39
years
and i raised uh corn wheat soybeans
a hundred head of uh of beef cattle and
i would like to say that i've urged the
administration to move swiftly
to provide aid to uh america's farmers
and uh but i said at the top of the show
we had a crisis
and when we're in the crisis in america
america always finds a way to rise up
over all of the obstacles that's in the
front of us and that's what we're going
to have to do right now for america's
farmers if we don't do that
and people have you been to the grocery
store lately i'm going to ask that
question look at the prices in today's
grocery stores go every week they're
going to continue they're going to
continue to rise if we don't fix the
problem
we have to be able to get our crops in
the ground right now and what the
president was talking about providing
aid for double cropping and and federal
crop insurance i found been farming for
39 years if i have the choice between
federal crop insurance and buying seed
and fertilizer i'm going to buy seed and
fertilizer every time
every time people now is the time to
move swiftly and to act precisely to get
america's farmers the aid that they need
and deserve to plant their crops on time
we have a 30-day window of opportunity
to plant
our crops this year and anytime after
that any farmer can tell you it's a wish
and die and and a gamble after that
people so we need the aid many of our uh
black farmers right now that uh don't
have farm operating loans in place
uh and uh they didn't get the debt
relief that we were supposed to to get
in usda's is reporting these farmers as
delinquents so they're really struggling
getting farm operating money that's what
we need we as farmers need
infrastructure uh uh
corporate 500 companies haven't done
enough to help america's farmers uh
companies like john deere they should be
cutting interest rates at this time for
for farmers and cog hill and all these
companies want to get bigger but they
don't tell us how they're going to help
the american farmer here
i want to wish you uh first thank you
and your fellow farmers for all the
great work you do
um thank you very much and and i wish
you the best um you feed all of us you
don't get enough credit for what you do
i appreciate you being with us and
really
shining a light on how bad this is thank
you john boyd you appreciate it hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else